Is it two? C++ should not be an ISO language? Or C other? I think C++ should leave ISO as a good title. C++ should leave ISO. All right. I mean, if you're listening and you've listened to this full episode, you already know what the title is 81 recorded on June 4th 2022. My name is Connor and today with my co host Bryce we talk about representation and C++ and whether C++ should be an ISO language. Sorry about that was having audio issues and I did not want to join before I resolved them. Well, it's all right because you said it would be 30 SCE, which is not a real unit of time. So you can just claim that however long you took, which is definitely longer than 30 seconds, was 30 SCE.
是两个吗？C++ 不应该是一门 ISO 语言？还是其他 C？我认为 C++ 应该保留 ISO 这个好名头。C++ 应该保留 ISO。行吧。我的意思是，如果你在听节目，而且听完了整期节目，你已经知道标题是什么了。录制于 2022 年 6 月 4 日。我是康纳（Connor），今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）将讨论 C++ 中的代表性问题，以及 C++ 是否应该是一门 ISO 语言。很抱歉，刚才遇到了一些音频问题，在解决之前我不想加入。好吧，没关系，因为你说过需要 30 SCE，这不是一个真实的时间单位。所以你大可以声称你花去的时间——绝对比 30 秒长——就是 30 SCE。
At least it wasn't 30 minutes. Yeah, in my defense, i have no real defense no i um i uh so i went bike riding last weekend and it's sort of like there was a huge rainstorm while i was out biking and i was like oh this is fun i like biking in the rain and there's no other people on the bike trail so i'll just keep going and that may have been uh not it it definitely killed my bike computer but uh it may have also killed my phone so i had to run around manhattan to to find a uh a place that could fix it yeah that's what you spent your beautiful saturday doing um i spent most of my saturday being lazy but then i spent like the my saturday evening running around manhattan trying to get my phone fixed yeah gotcha gotcha how's it going buddy what are we talking about
至少不是 30 分钟。对，为自己辩解一下，其实我没什么好辩解的。不，我……我……上周末我去骑自行车了，在我骑车的时候突然下了一场大雨，当时我想，噢，这挺有意思的，我喜欢在雨中骑车，而且自行车道上也没有其他人，所以我决定继续骑下去。这可能……这绝对弄坏了我的自行车码表，但它可能也弄坏了我的手机，所以我不得不跑遍曼哈顿去寻找一个能修理它的地方。是啊，这就是你度过美好星期六的方式。我星期六的大部分时间都在偷懒，但后来我花了大概整个周六晚上的时间在曼哈顿到处跑，试图修好我的手机。啊，明白了，明白了。最近怎么样，老兄？我们今天在聊什么呢？
today um i don't know aren't you the one who's supposed to aren't you aren't you the the director here and i'm just uh i'm just along for the ride all right if that's the case episode 80 last week's episode today is june 4th saturday we are recording in the evening which typically is not the case i don't think we've ever have we ever recorded on on a Saturday evening? Maybe, but not that I can recall. And we usually record on Saturday mornings. But today we're recording on Saturday evening, June 4th. This will be coming out on June 10th. And it will be episode 81. Episode 80 was a week ago, and I have started occasionally. It started sort of with Ben Dean's four-part saga posting to the CPP subreddit. And up until today or yesterday, we have not gotten any comments.
今天……我不知道，难道你不是那个应该……难道你不是这里的总监吗？而我只是来搭顺风车的。好吧，既然如此，第 80 期，也就是上周的节目。今天是 6 月 4 日，星期六。我们在晚上录音，这通常是不可能的。我不认为我们以前……我们曾经在周六晚上录过音吗？也许有，但我不记得了。我们通常在周六早上录音。但今天我们在 6 月 4 日星期六的晚上录音。这期节目将在 6 月 10 日发布。这将是第 81 期节目。第 80 期节目是一周前发布的，我开始偶尔……这起因于本·迪恩（Ben Dean）在 CPP 子版块上发布的四部分系列文章。直到今天或昨天，我们还没有收到任何评论。
We usually get, you know, 10 or 20 upvotes whatever but uh we had three comments on the first post of one of our episodes on subreddit and so i figured one we'll read them out and we'll get bryce's we'll get bryce's response because he's the expert when it comes to gpus i mean olivier geroux is the real expert but um in the absence of his presence uh bryce is the expert and um also i feel like uh i really enjoyed uh the last half of our conversation last time i wouldn't i wouldn't go so far as to claim that i'm an expert in gpus relative to me you definitely no, I think it's a different class of expertise, which is that my expertise is in parallel programming. You know, I've done a lot
我们通常会得到，你知道的，10 个或 20 个赞之类的。但在子版块上我们节目的第一篇帖子下有三条评论，所以我想，第一，我们要把它们读出来，听听布莱斯的反应，因为在 GPU 方面他才是专家——我是说奥利维耶·吉鲁（Olivier Geroux）才是真正的专家，但是……在座没有他的情况下，布莱斯就是专家。而且……我也觉得……我很享受上一次我们谈话的后半部分。我不会走得太远，去声称自己是 GPU 方面的专家。相对于我而言，你绝对……不，我认为这是不同类别的专业知识，我的专业知识在于并行编程。你知道，我做过很多
of things. I've worn a lot of hats. And certainly the hats that I wear today are more in the space of like programming language design and library design. But I think the only thing that I actually have any like real expertise in is, is parallelism. Like, you know, like I'm not a library designer on par with, you know, an Eric Niebler or really a compiler expert or a language expert. But I do know a thing or two about parallel programming. And I would definitely say, relative to me, you understand the GPU programming model definitely a lot better.
事情。我扮演过很多角色。当然，我今天扮演的角色更多是在编程语言设计和库设计领域。但我认为我真正拥有任何真正专业知识的领域只有并行性。就像，你知道的，我不是那种能与埃里克·尼布勒（Eric Niebler）相提并论的库设计者，也不是真正的编译器专家或语言专家。但我确实对并行编程略知一二。而且我肯定会说，相对于我而言，你对 GPU 编程模型的理解确实要好得多。
Well, I actually find the GPU programming model, in particular the hardware model, how the hardware actually works under the hood, to be very challenging, especially in comparison to sort of the architecture of a CPU, which I feel like I have a good, I can wrap my head around pretty well. It may be one of those things where the more you know, the more you're aware of what you don't know. But yeah, I certainly don't feel like I'm somebody that has an expert level of knowledge about GPUs. Well, we shall proceed to talk about GPUpus today and get whatever expertise you have out of you and into mine and the listener's brain and before we do that what do i have here bryce or actually you can't see it
嗯，我其实觉得 GPU 编程模型，尤其是硬件模型，即硬件在底层是如何实际运作的，是非常具有挑战性的，特别是与 CPU 的架构相比，我觉得 CPU 的架构我可以很好地理解和掌握。这可能是那种“你知道的越多，就越意识到自己不知道的越多”的情况之一。但是，是的，我当然不觉得自己是一个对 GPU 拥有专家级知识的人。好吧，我们今天将继续讨论 GPU，并把你所拥有的专业知识从你脑子里榨取出来，装进我和听众的脑子里。在此之前，我这里有什么，布莱斯？或者其实你看不到……
my cannot see my magic background screening yeah my but i know but that probably means that it's green no it is not it is, and it is a bubbly. It's been a while, listener, and your patience has been rewarded with the crisp opening of a blackberry bubbly. Let me tell you, it's the best flavor. And bubbly, if you happen to be listening, my pinned tweet on at ADSP, the podcast Twitter profile, is a fridge full of bubblies. I don't know what we're doing without a sponsorship from you still. I've had multiple people. We're talking about big names like Tony Van Eerd and not big names like other people. I mean, they don't know who Tony is anyway, so I don't know why I'm name dropping.
看不到我的魔幻虚拟背景。是的，但我知道，但这可能意味着它是绿色的。不，它不是，它是 Bubbly 气泡水。好久不见了，听众朋友们，你们的耐心得到了回报，伴随着黑莓味 Bubbly 气泡水清脆的开罐声。我跟你说，这是最好的口味。Bubbly，如果你碰巧在听的话，我在 ADSP 的置顶推文——这个播客的推特账号上——发了一张塞满 Bubbly 气泡水的冰箱的照片。我不知道为什么我们到现在还没有你们的赞助。我有好几个人……我们说的是像托尼·范埃尔德（Tony Van Eerd）这样的大人物，以及像其他人这样不出名的人。我的意思是，反正他们也不知道托尼是谁，所以我不知道我为什么要借他的大名来抬高身价。
But anyways, multiple people have told me that they've purchased the bubblies. And I feel like the sponsorship is right around the corner, Bryce. Moving on to the comments. Episode 80 was entitled C++ Multidimensional Arrays and GPUs, where we talked about multidimensional iterators and adjacent topics. Our first comment, do you actually, I am not going to know the last name. You probably do. The Reddit user is James20k. He is the color expert and GPU expert that showed up at one of the committee meetings
但无论如何，好几个人告诉我他们都买了 Bubbly 气泡水。我觉得赞助真的就在拐角处了，布莱斯。接下来看评论。第 80 期的标题是《C++ 多维数组与GPU》，我们在其中讨论了多维迭代器和相关主题。我们的第一条评论……其实我不知道这个姓氏，你可能知道。Reddit 用户是 James20k。他就是那位带着对 2D 图形提案的批评意见出席某次委员会会议的图形专家和 GPU 专家。
with critiques of the 2D graphics proposal. Yeah. Do you know his last name? I don't off the top of my head. He's a good guy. Yeah. I mean, super, super super knowledgeable on he's probably a gpu expert james barrow if i'm pronouncing that correctly b-e-r-r-o-w at first because i
是的。你知道他的姓氏吗？我一下子想不起来了。他是个好人。是的，我的意思是，他在……上超级、超级、超级博学。他可能是一个 GPU 专家，詹姆斯·巴罗（James Barrow），如果我没读错的话，拼法是 b-e-r-r-o-w。一开始因为我……
i definitely know that he published a paper but when i searched for it it did not come up but then i searched for him as a cpp cast guest and or actually no he shows up as a cpp chat our rival podcast currently the number one c++ active c++ i realized on upon editing episode 79 um that uh technically cpp cast is still the number one c++ podcast and will be for some time it's just not active anymore. So we should be we should be clear. And now that I now that I am making corrections, we should make a couple corrections here that have been 10 episodes overdue. Oh, right. First of all, I was talking to someone a couple months ago at this point, and they said, Could you do me a favor and give a shout out to Indian C++ programmers? And I said, sure.
我确信他发表过一篇论文，但当我搜索时却没有找到。不过后来我搜到他是 CPP Cast 的嘉宾，或者其实不对，他是 CPP Chat 的嘉宾——这是我们的竞争播客，目前排名第一的 C++……在编辑第 79 期节目时我意识到……技术上讲，CPP Cast 仍然是排名第一的 C++ 播客，而且在一段时间内仍将如此，只是它不再活跃了。所以我们应该把话说清楚。既然我……既然我正在做纠正，我们在这里应该做几个迟到了 10 期的纠正。哦，对了。首先，几个月前我和某个人交谈过，他们说：“你能帮个忙，向印度的 C++ 程序员致意吗？”我说：“没问题。”
And he was like, yeah, I just feel like at all the conferences other than C++ India, Indian C++ programmers are like severely underrepresented. I actually, I talked about this at CPP India last year when I was giving my keynote there. Yeah. I talked about this problem and how it's a problem that we should solve. I mean, statistically speaking, I would guess that based on country, the most C++ developers are either Indian or Chinese,
然后他说：“对，我觉得除了 C++ India 之外，在所有其他会议上，印度的 C++ 程序员都被严重代表不足了。”其实，我去年在印度的 C++ 会议上发表主题演讲时就谈过这件事。是的。我谈到了这个问题，以及这是一个我们应该解决的问题。从统计学角度讲，我猜根据国家来看，最多的 C++ 开发者要么是印度人，要么是中国人，
just on the numbers game. But just a question for you, why don't we see Indian or Chinese programmers? I mean, I don't know. That's a good question. Well, until recently, there was no Chinese delegation to the C++ committee. That's changed. Now there's a few who are participating.
仅就人口基数而言。但有个问题想问你，为什么我们看不到印度或中国程序员呢？我的意思是，我不知道。这是个好问题。嗯，直到最近，C++ 委员会中还没有中国代表团。情况已经变了。现在有一些人参与进来了。
And there's still no Indian delegation to the C++ committee, not for lack of trying. It's a lot of people interested, but the way that the C++ committee works, you have to go through whatever your country's process is for joining, for forming a national committee. And in some countries, that's more complicated than others. And it seems that India is a more challenging one, because basically we've not been able to get anybody to reply to emails about how they know this is the organization that we should reach out to, but they can't really get in touch with anybody. Now, why is this important? So I think I may have talked about this in the past on ADSP, but the reason that I joined the committee back in the day, I was just involved at C++ conferences in the C++ community the first few years of my career. But I realized that if you're going to be involved, if you want to make a name for yourself in a tech community, you really have
并且 C++ 委员会中仍然没有印度代表团，这并不是因为没有尝试。有很多人对此感兴趣，但 C++ 委员会的运作方式是，你必须通过你所在国家的加入流程、组建国家委员会的流程。在某些国家，这比在其他国家更复杂。而且看起来印度是一个更具挑战性的国家，因为基本上我们没能让任何人回复关于如何认识到这是我们应该联系的组织的电子邮件，但他们真的无法与任何人取得联系。现在，为什么这很重要？所以我想我过去可能在 ADSP 上谈过这一点，但我当年加入委员会的原因是，在我职业生涯的前几年，我只参与了 C++ 会议和 C++ 社区。但我意识到，如果你想参与其中，如果你想在科技社区中崭露头角，你真的必须
to be involved in the leadership and the decision making. And ultimately, like, where does the decision making about C++, the language, come from? Well, it comes from the committee. And so, you know, think about all the people who go and give talks at big C++ conferences. They're, you know, oftentimes they're people who are involved in the committee because being involved in the committee means that you can talk about the work that you've done in the committee. You can talk about the future direction of C++. And if you're not on the committee, it's a lot harder to give that sort of talk and to be involved in sort of the global C++ leadership. And so I think one of the reasons for this weird inequity, because there are a ton of C++ programmers in India and China, but one of the reasons why we don't see,
参与到领导层和决策制定中来。归根结底，关于 C++ 这门语言的决策制定来自哪里？嗯，它来自委员会。所以，你知道，想想所有去大型 C++ 会议上做演讲的人。他们通常是参与委员会的人，因为参与委员会意味着你可以谈论你在委员会中所做的工作。你可以谈论 C++ 的未来发展方向。如果你不在委员会中，要进行那种演讲并参与全球 C++ 领导层的工作要困难得多。所以我认为这种奇怪的不平等现象的原因之一是——因为印度和中国有大量的 C++ 程序员——但我们看不到的原因之一，
why we see such a Eurocentric, you know, C++ conferencing, I think, is in part because the C++ committee and sort of the structure of the international standards organization that we're involved in has not been conducive to participation from that part of the globe. So you think that there's a very strong correlation between committee representation based on country and speakers at conferences? Yeah, not only speakers at conferences, but also where we hold C++ conferences. There's a lot of tech conferences that get held in Asia, but there's not that many C++ conferences. And most of the C++ conferences that you can point to in that, those time zones, like the ones that comes to mind, like Pacific Plus Plus, which is, you know, that's in another country that has historically been very involved in standards or has had involvement in the ISO standards in the same way that a lot of the EU countries and the U.S. has. development of C++ has sort of been in some ways hindered by this odd model, which requires you to go through your national body. And as you can imagine, you know, China and India are very big countries. And so the, you know, the parts of those countries that deal with
为什么我们会看到如此以欧洲为中心的 C++ 会议，我认为，部分原因是因为 C++ 委员会以及我们参与的国际标准化组织的结构一直不利于来自世界那个地区的参与。所以你认为基于国家的委员会代表性与会议演讲者之间存在着非常强的相关性？是的，不仅是会议演讲者，还包括我们举办 C++ 会议的地点。有很多科技会议在亚洲举行，但并没有那么多 C++ 会议。而且你可以指出的、位于那些时区的绝大多数 C++ 会议，比如我想到的那些，比如 Pacific Plus Plus，你知道的，那是在另一个历史上一直非常深入参与标准制定、或者像许多欧盟国家和美国那样参与了 ISO 标准制定的国家里。C++ 的发展在某些方面因这种奇怪的模式而受到阻碍，该模式要求你必须通过你的国家机构。正如你所想象的那样，中国和印度是非常大的国家，所以那些处理
international standards, you know, those are not going to be small agencies because they're dealing with, you know, large countries with a lot of different stakeholders and constituents. And so understandably, it's not, you know, it's a little bit more challenging to get established there. I think in a lot of other countries, and especially in a lot of, you know, smaller countries, it tends to be a bit easier. Because it's like, oh, it's like, you know, maybe it's a smaller office, and it's just easier to get in touch with the right people. Yeah, it's a real shame.
国际标准的国家部门，不会是什么小型机构，因为他们面对的是拥有许多不同利益相关者和选民的大国。因此可以理解的是，在那里建立起来会更具挑战性。我认为在许多其他国家，特别是在许多较小的国家，情况往往会容易一些。因为就像是，哦，可能是一个较小的办公室，与合适的人取得联系会更容易。是的，这真的很遗憾。
It is, yeah. I guess that's the thing, is i know that there is c++ india or india c++ i'm actually not sure which way it's pronounced but there's also i know i don't know the name of the conference but i know kate gregory and a couple other speakers have been invited and have spoken at like a c++ china conference where i think the majority of the talks are in Chinese. But yeah, it's just, I think it's surprising from like a statistical point of view when you just, I'm not sure if you've read any or the listeners have read any like behavioral economics and like sort of bias books, but one of them is called base rate neglect, where they phrase these questions in such a way that you neglect the base rate where 95% of the population,
确实如此，是的。我想这就是情况所在，我知道有 C++ India 或者 India C++——我其实不确定具体该怎么发音——但我也知道……我不知道会议的名字，但我知道凯特·格雷戈里（Kate Gregory）和其他几位演讲者曾被邀请并在 C++ 中国会议上发言，我想那里的绝大多数演讲都是用中文进行的。但是，是的，从统计学的角度来看，这让人感到惊讶，如果你只是……我不确定你或听众是否读过任何行为经济学和偏见方面的书籍，其中一本叫做“基数忽略（base rate neglect）”，他们提出这些问题的方式会让你忽略基数，即 95% 的人口，
like there's 95% of the people that you're asking about fall into one group. Like I'm trying to think what's an example of one of these questions where they ask about like, you pick a person at random from the US population. And what's more likely that you, this person at random is a female librarian or a female farmer? And I'll give dramatic pause for a couple seconds. And when they've given this quiz or, you know, sort of they've done, conducted these kinds of questions in these studies, they tap into the fact that, you know, people associate librarian as a female profession. And so most people say, and farmer as sort of a more male profession. And so they'll say, well, female librarians, it's more likely that you randomly chose that person. But it ignores the base rate of the fact that there are like, for every one
比如有 95% 的你所询问的人属于某一群体。就像我在想，其中一个问题的例子是什么，他们问，比如你从美国人口中随机挑选一个人。这个人随机是一名女性图书管理员还是一名女性农民，哪个可能性更大？我会停顿戏剧性的几秒钟。当他们做这个测验时，或者说，当他们在这些研究中进行这类提问时，他们利用了这样一个事实，即人们将图书管理员与女性职业联系在一起。所以大多数人会说，而农民则更像是一个男性的职业。因此他们会说，嗯，女性图书管理员，你随机选择那个人的可能性更大。但这忽略了基本比率的事实，即对于每一个
librarian, there's like 20 or 100 farmers. I can't remember the exact numbers. But like the point being is that like overwhelmingly, like farmer is a much more popular or there's way more farmers than there are librarians. So like the gender part of farmer or librarian actually does not matter in this question. It's really asking what's more likely, like farmer or librarian. And it ignores sort of the base rate statistic of, you know, what's more common. And just based on population, there's like, what, 1.6 billion people in India and 1.4 in China or something, plus or minus 200 million or something like that, compared to, you know, the United States, which is 330 million in Europe, you know, there's still a lot of, you know, Western folks. But it's just surprising that you, when this person asked me to shout out, said, shout out to C++ Indian programmers.
图书管理员，大约有 20 个或 100 个农民。我记不清确切的数字了。但重点是，绝大多数情况下，农民是一个更受欢迎的职业，或者农民的数量远远多于图书管理员。所以，农民或图书管理员的性别部分在这个问题中其实并不重要。它真正问的是哪个可能性更大，比如农民还是图书管理员。它忽略了关于什么更常见的基本比率统计数据。仅根据人口来看，印度有大约 16 亿人，中国有 14 亿人左右，上下浮动 2 亿左右，相比之下，你知道，美国有 3.3 亿人，欧洲有……你知道，仍然有很多西方人。但令人惊奇的是，当这个人要求我致意时，他说：“向印度的 C++ 程序员致意。”
He was like, there's a ton of us. And like, you know, you don't see them speaking at European conferences or conferences in the United States. Yeah, well, and that's exactly one of the problems there is that C++ conferences are predominantly European and U.S. conferences. And the international C++ committee is primarily a NATO committee. If you look at who's involved in ISO, it skews towards a certain set of countries. And so, you know, that really sort of skews things. You know, another facet of this, you know, in both China and Indian nationals need a visa to go to most of the places where the C++ committee meets and also need a visa to go to most of the places where C++ conferences are.
他说：“我们有海量的人。”而且，你知道，你看不到他们在欧洲会议或美国会议上发言。是的，而这正是其中的问题之一，即 C++ 会议主要是欧洲和美国的会议。国际 C++ 委员会主要是一个北约委员会。如果你看看谁参与了 ISO，它偏向于某一组特定的国家。所以，你知道，这确实使情况变得偏颇。这的另一个方面是，中国和印度的国民去 C++ 委员会开会的绝大多数地方都需要签证，而且去 C++ 会议的大多数地方也需要签证。
And I just, coincidentally, last week, I happened to be looking at the wait times to get an appointment at the U.S. consulate, or I guess U.S. embassy in New Delhi for just a regular traveler's visa to the U.S. So you want to guess how, if you're an Indian national and you wanted to get an appointment to get a visa that comes to the U.S. for a conference, you want to guess how long the website says the wait is at the U.S. Embassy in New Delhi? I mean, I'll guess, ignoring the fact that you're asking this, which means that it's going to be a longer time. But if you had just asked me out of the blue, I would have said, I don't know, less than a month, three or four weeks or something. Yeah. So I believe, and I'm going to, I'm going to check it right now just to be, to be sure, because there's a little website where you can go to check this. Um, uh, so, so it, so it's down from what it was a week ago. Um, so when I checked a week ago, the time, the appointment wait time for visa visitor visa was 731 days it's it's it but
而且我刚好就在上周，查看了在美国驻新德里领事馆——或者我想是美国大使馆——预约普通赴美旅游签证的等待时间。所以你想猜一下，如果你是一个印度国民，想要预约获得来美国参加会议的签证，你想猜一下网站上显示美国驻新德里大使馆的等待时间是多久吗？我的意思是，我会猜——忽略你提出这个问题这一事实，这意味着时间会很长。但如果你突发奇想问我，我大概会说，我不知道，少于一个月，三四周左右吧。对。所以我想——我马上要查一下以确保万无一失，因为有一个小网站你可以去查看这个。嗯……所以它比一周前有所下降。所以当我一周前检查时，访客签证的预约等待时间是 731 天。它……但
the good news is it's down now it's down now to only 291 days so if you want to go to uh to the cpp con um 2022 um uh yeah probably you should have been planning that a few months ago. But the good news is, if you start planning right now, you might be able to go to speak at CPPCon 2023. Now, I don't know whether that website is actually accurate. That is the U.S. government website that I use to check this whenever I need to help somebody with a visa appointment. Maybe the situation, the actual situation on the ground is not as bad as it sounds. But the fact is, most of the speakers from European countries who want to come to CPPCon or some other US-based conference or to a committee meeting in the US, they don't need to
好消息是它下降了，现在它已经下降到只有 291 天了。所以如果你想去参加 CPP Con 2022……嗯……是的，你可能几个月前就该开始计划了。但好消息是，如果你现在开始计划，你可能就能去在 CPP Con 2023 上发言了。现在，我不知道那个网站是否真的准确。每当我需要帮别人预约签证时，我都会用那个美国政府网站来检查。也许情况，实地的实际情况并没有听起来那么糟。但事实是，大多数来自欧洲国家的、想来 CPP Con 或其他美国本土会议或美国委员会会议的演讲者，他们不需要
worry about that because they don't need a visa. And it's, you know, it's similar situation for folks coming from China. Yeah, it's a real, it's a real problem. Yeah, hopefully, I don't really know what the solution is. But well, I mean, I think this, this, there's a few different aspects of what is the solution. One aspect of it is, you know, the, like, there's the underlying problem, which is sort of the model for membership on the C++ committee is, you know, probably not what we would want it to be and is unnecessarily restrictive. Whether or not and how you participate in C++ evolution should not depend upon your nationality. I don't think that that's a radical statement,
担心这个问题，因为他们不需要签证。对于来自中国的人来说情况也是类似。是的，这真的是个大问题。是的，希望如此，我真的不知道解决办法是什么。但是，好吧，我认为这……有几个不同的方面来探讨什么是解决方案。其中一个方面是，你知道，存在底层问题，即 C++ 委员会的成员资格模型可能不是我们想要的，而且是不必要的限制性的。你是否以及如何参与 C++ 的演进不应该取决于你的国籍。我不认为这是一个激进的声明，
but the reality today is that it does. Yeah. That the role that you can play in the C++ committee depends upon what country you're a citizen of. That shouldn't be the case. But changing, making that not be the case requires, you know, very radical changes to the C++ committee and the very way in which we involve C++. And I mean, I'm personally an advocate of us making those changes, but whether or not that's practical is a different question.
但今天的现实是，它的确取决于国籍。是的。你在 C++ 委员会中能扮演的角色取决于你是什么国家的公民。本不该如此。但要改变这一点，使之不再如此，需要对 C++ 委员会以及我们参与 C++ 的方式进行非常激进的改变。我的意思是，我个人主张我们做出这些改变，但这是否切合实际是另一个问题。
So what can we do within the current system? Well, I think the easiest solution is to get national committees formed in those countries. Now, China already has one, and we've seen more and more participation from the Chinese committee in the past few years, but it's still only a few people. And because in part of some of the issues I talked about before, visa is also the issue of time zones and cost of travel. Before the pandemic, we had some participation from the Chinese committee, but we didn't have a lot of members of the Chinese committee coming to our committee meetings. And it's the same for Japan. The Japanese National Committee for C++ has actually been involved for a long time, for decades, but has not typically sent people to committee meetings. Not sure entirely the reasons
那么在现有系统内我们能做些什么呢？嗯，我认为最简单的解决方案是在这些国家建立国家委员会。现在，中国已经有一个了，而且在过去几年里我们看到中国委员会的参与度越来越高，但仍然只有几个人。部分原因是我之前谈到的一些问题，签证也是时区和差旅成本的问题。在疫情爆发之前，我们有一些来自中国委员会的参与者，但并没有很多中国委员会的成员来参加我们的委员会会议。日本也是如此。日本的 C++ 国家委员会实际上已经参与了很长时间，长达几十年，但通常不会派人参加委员会会议。我不完全清楚其中的原因
there, but one might imagine that one of the reasons is that the travel is, you know, a bit prohibitive. But getting more involvement and larger delegations from, you know, these underrepresented countries would be a good first step. And then that will help get more people from those countries involved in leadership. And then they'll have more things to talk about at a conference. And then maybe we could even have committee meetings in some of those countries. This model of like, oh, you want to build up a C++ community in your country, form a national body, it's been very successful in other countries. Israel, you know, I went to Core C++, the first one, in 2017 or 2018.
，但可以想象原因之一是差旅成本有点过于高昂。不过，获得来自这些代表性不足的国家的更多参与和更大的代表团，将是一个好的第一步。然后这将有助于让来自这些国家的更多人参与到领导层中来。接着他们就会有更多的话题可以在会议上讨论。然后也许我们甚至可以在其中一些国家举行委员会会议。这种模式，比如“哦，你想在你的国家建立一个 C++ 社区，成立一个国家机构”，在其他国家已经非常成功了。以色列，你知道，我在 2017 或 2018 年参加了第一届 Core C++。
Maybe it was 2019 um and i gave a lightning talk there which was basically hey israel should form a national body and like here's the rough steps of what you need to do it um and subsequently um israel did form a national body has gotten involved in the c++ committee and now there are um people from the israeli national body who are involved in the c++ committee leadership and who regularly give talks at the c++ conferences. And they're able to go back to their user groups in their country and talk about what's going on in the committee. And that helps, you know, that helps get the local C++ developers in your country more involved. Yeah. And it definitely does. It definitely does have an impact because one of those people, I believe, that's on the Israel National Body is Imba Levy. And she was just a part of, I don't actually know what it was, but over the past couple weeks meeting C++, or maybe it was months, but like the videos went online for some kind of mini conference where folks like Kate Gregory, Andre Alexandrescu, Imbal Levy, they all gave these sort of five to
可能是 2019 年，我在那里做了一次闪电演讲，内容基本上是“嘿，以色列应该成立一个国家机构，这里是你需要做的粗略步骤”。随后，以色列确实成立了一个国家机构，并参与进了 C++ 委员会，现在有来自以色列国家机构的人员参与了 C++ 委员会的领导层，并且经常在 C++ 会议上发表演讲。他们能够回到自己国家的各个用户组，谈论委员会中正在发生的事情。这有助于，你知道的，让你们国家的本地 C++ 开发者更多地参与进来。是的。而且它确实有影响。它绝对会产生影响，因为其中一个人，我相信，是以色列国家机构的成员伊姆巴·利维（Imba Levy）。她刚刚参与了……我其实不知道那是什么，但在过去几周的 Meeting C++ 会议上，或者可能是几个月，一些迷你会议的视频上线了，凯特·格雷戈里、安德烈·亚历山德雷斯库（Andrei Alexandrescu）、伊姆巴·利维等人在会上都进行了这些大约 5 到 15 分钟的闪电演讲。
15 minute lightning talks. And there was a panel about technical speaking. So it was all focused around how to give talks and tips on talks and stuff like that. And so I think definitely your point of having people join leadership and that having an effect that these individuals from different countries will start popping up in more conference circuits. Yeah, it definitely seems to be true, at least from a couple anecdotal examples. And I just sent you a link to a tweet that I saw when I was waiting for the subway earlier, that I think illustrates sort of my first point in what we should do about this.
还有一个关于技术演讲的小组讨论。所以这一切都围绕着如何进行演讲、演讲的技巧等展开。所以我认为，你关于让人们加入领导层并产生这种效果的观点是绝对正确的，来自不同国家的这些个人将开始在更多的会议巡回活动中露面。是的，这绝对是真的，至少从几个坊间例子来看是这样。我刚刚给你发了一个推特链接，那是我早些时候等地铁时看到的，我认为它说明了我关于我们应该如何解决这个问题的第一点的看法。
And it was a tweet about the Rust project. And somebody said, this is James Munn who tweeted this, said, the Rust project is bonkers, y'all. I submitted an ICE, that's internal compiler error type of compiler bug 15 hours ago. So we submitted a bug report 15 hours ago. I minimized it 14 hours ago. Someone opened a PR with a UI test 12 hours ago. They added a solid fix 10 hours ago, and it's already waiting for a roll-up merge.
这是一条关于 Rust 项目的推特。有人说——这是詹姆斯·芒恩（James Munn）发的一条推特——说：“Rust 项目太疯狂了各位。我 15 小时前提交了一个 ICE，也就是内部编译器错误类型的编译器 bug。所以我们在 15 小时前提交了一个 bug 报告。我在 14 小时前将其简化。有人在 12 小时前提交了一个带有 UI 测试的 PR。他们在 10 小时前添加了一个可靠的修复，它已经在一个合并队列中等待合并了。”
Chances are it'll land in stable in Rust 1.62 in 25 days, which means our workaround won't be needed past the end of the month. I joined the C++ committee in 2015 with my primary intention being to get multidimensional array support into the library in some form. And it's 2022 and it's not, it's not certain that it'll go into 2023. It will hopefully will, but then it won't be available in compilers for another three years. And I, you know, that's, that's a difference of a feature
“很有可能它将在 25 天内登陆 Rust 1.62 的稳定版，这意味着到月底我们的变通方法就不需要了。”我在 2015 年加入 C++ 委员会，我的主要意图是以某种形式将多维数组支持引入库中。现在是 2022 年，它还没有……还不确定能否进入 2023 年。希望会的，但随后它在三年内都不会在编译器中可用。而且，你知道，这是一个特性与
versus a bug fix, but I I'm aware of fixes, too, that have taken similar time frames. And, you know, you compare the development model or the evolution model for a modern language like Rust to the development or evolution model for a language like C++. And it really makes you question whether the system as it is really serves us well. Yeah, that's kind of depressing. You heard it here first, folks. Rust made two C++ developers sad today. Yeah. I mean, if Rust has many good things going for it,
一个 bug 修复的区别，但我知道有些修复也经历了类似的时间框架。而且，你将像 Rust 这样的现代语言的开发模型或演进模型，与像 C++ 这样的语言的开发或演进模型进行比较，这真的让你怀疑现有的系统是否真的对我们很有帮助。是的，这有点令人沮丧。各位，你们在这里听到了第一手消息。Rust 让两个 C++ 开发者今天感到难过了。是的。我的意思是，Rust 有很多优点，
but the thing that makes it most competitive with C++ is not any technical feature of Rust. The thing that makes Rust most competitive with C++ is the Rust community and the Rust model for the development of the language. I mean, you could make an argument for Cargo. It's a package manager. But I think that's maybe sort of a part of what I'm talking about.
但让它最具竞争力的是 C++ 的地方，不是 Rust 的任何技术特性。让 Rust 最具竞争力的是 Rust 社区以及 Rust 语言的开发模型。我的意思是，你可以为 Cargo 争辩。它是一个包管理器。但我认为这也许是我在谈论的一部分。
Okay. All right. Continue then. Yeah. But really, I think the Rust community and the ability to work far more efficiently and to have a much better stakeholder model where people can participate regardless of their national origin without having to travel around the world to physical meetings. You know, that means that Rust can move faster than C++. So it doesn't
好的。好吧，继续吧。是的。但 realmente，我认为 Rust 社区以及更高效工作、拥有一个更好的利益相关者模型的能力——人们无论国籍如何都可以参与，而不必为了物理会议环游世界——这意味着 Rust 的行动可以比 C++ 更快。所以
matter where Rust is today and where C++ is today. The important thing is that Rust will be able to evolve and get better faster. And that is, that ultimately spells trouble for a language like C++. And I mean, I say spell, I say spells trouble. It's not like they're, it's not like they're in a competition and we should use whatever the best tool is. But C++ will not be able to be the best tool if it is not able to evolve in a modern fashion. Do you think there's any chance of a governance model change? I think it's a lot more likely than one or two years ago. What does that mean numerically? Like, are we talking still low single-digit percentages kind of thing?
Rust 今天在哪里，C++ 今天在哪里，这并不重要。重要的是 Rust 将能够以更快的速度演进并变得更好。这最终对像 C++ 这样的语言来说是个麻烦。我的意思是，我说这是个麻烦，并不是说它们……并不是说它们在竞争，我们应该使用最好的工具。但如果 C++ 不能以现代的方式演进，它就无法成为最好的工具。你认为治理模式有任何改变的可能性吗？我认为这比一到两年前更有可能了。这在数字上意味着什么？比如，我们谈论的仍然是低个位数百分比的那种情况吗？
I'm not going to comment on that. I mean, I think that for C++ to survive, C++ must leave ISO. There's simply no way around it. ISO is the wrong organization to evolve a technology standard like C++. This has been proven time and time again. I think almost everybody on the committee and in the C++ community would agree with that. Most people also believe that that's not possible for a variety of reasons. I think some people may believe that it's possible, may believe that it could be a good thing, but have serious misgivings or concerns about, you know, that a potential, you know, different thing could be worse than the status quo. But I think that almost everybody would agree that the status quo is not optimal.
我对这一点不予置评。我的意思是，我认为为了让 C++ 生存下来，C++ 必须离开 ISO。对此绝对没有别的办法。ISO 是演进 C++ 这样的技术标准的错误组织。这一点已经被一次又一次地证明了。我认为委员会和 C++ 社区中的几乎所有人都同意这一点。大多数人还认为，由于种种原因，这是不可能的。我认为有些人可能认为这是可能的，可能认为这是一件好事，但对于潜在的、不同的事物可能会比现状更糟糕，有着严重的疑虑或担忧。但我认为几乎所有人都同意现状并不是最优的。
And I think is increasingly getting worse as time goes on. And the pandemic, I think, has really demonstrated that. So, yeah, I think C++ must leave ISO. I mean, I would even go so far as to say I think all of the programming languages standards that are currently developed by SC22 should leave ISO for some better model. You know, they could continue to be ISO standards, but they should be developed by some other organization, as many ISO standards are. All right, so we'll start to wrap up this episode that clearly did not become about our Reddit comments on episode 80. The question is, though, Bryce, what should the title of this episode be?
而且随着时间的推移，情况似乎越来越糟。我认为疫情真正证明了这一点。所以，是的，我认为 C++ 必须离开 ISO。我的意思是，我甚至要说，我认为目前由 SC22 开发的所有编程语言标准都应该为了某种更好的模型而离开 ISO。你知道，它们可以继续成为 ISO 标准，但它们应该由其他一些组织来开发，就像许多 ISO 标准一样。好了，我们要开始结束这一期显然没有变成关于我们在第 80 期节目中 Reddit 评论的节目了。不过问题是，布莱斯，这期节目的标题应该是什么？
Is it A, where are all the Chinese and Indian C++ developers? I mean, I said that out loud, and I realized they're in China and India mostly probably. So maybe that's a bad title. Is it two C++ should not be an ISO language or C other? I think C++ should leave ISO. C++ should leave ISO. All right. I mean, if you're listening
是 A：中国和印度的 C++ 开发者都在哪里？我的意思是，我大声说出来了，我意识到他们大多可能在中国和印度。所以也许那是个不好的标题。是二：C++ 不应该是一门 ISO 语言，还是其他 C？我认为 C++ 应该离开 ISO。C++ 应该离开 ISO。好吧。我的意思是，如果你在听，
and you've listened to this full episode, you already know what the title is, but we decided it live here. And yeah, is there anything we should say to potential folks in India that are interested in having more representation on the global C++ scale? Is there anything they can do in order to get their national body created? So the, there's the, you know, I, I about a year or two ago, I'm always, I'm always trying to recruit more national bodies because I believe having more countries involved is good. Um, and like I, I was trying the most recently, I think India and Mexico were the two I was trying to help out. And both of those countries have faced the same problem where there was, there were vibrant, active user groups with lots of people who, you know, could
而且你听完了整期节目，你已经知道标题是什么了，但我们在这里现场决定了它。是的，我们对印度那些有兴趣在全球 C++ 规模上获得更多代表性的潜在人员有什么要说的吗？他们可以做些什么来创建他们的国家机构？所以，有……你知道的，我大约一两年以前，我一直在试图招募更多的国家委员会，因为我相信有更多国家参与是件好事。而且就像我最近一直在尝试的，我认为印度和墨西哥是我一直在试图帮助的两个国家。这两个国家都面临着同样的问题，那就是那里有充满活力、活跃的用户组，里面有很多可以
serve as experts. But, and we've, you know, we've gone through the process, we've figured out what is the, you know, the national standards organization within their country. And the problem in both cases have been getting in contact with that organization and actually figuring out, getting in touch with somebody who can actually make it happen. And I believe that remains the holdup in both cases. I'd say if you're interested, that C++ India um user group i think there's one or two big ones but i believe the leaders of both of those user groups are involved um but ultimately it's going to take you know somebody at the i forget the name of the the standards organization in India, but somebody at that standards organization has to, has to,
担任专家的人。但是，而且我们已经，你知道的，经历了整个过程，我们已经弄清楚了他们国内的国家标准化组织是什么。但两个案例中的问题一直都是与该组织取得联系，并实际找出一个能够真正促成此事的人。我相信这在两方面仍然是阻碍。我想说，如果你感兴趣，那个 C++ India 用户组——我想有一两个大的，但我相信这两个用户组的领导者都参与进来了——但归根结底，这需要，你知道的，在……我忘了印度标准化组织的名字了，但在那个标准化组织里的某个人必须，必须
you know, check some email inbox. Yeah. Um, and it's often the problem just not being in touch with the right people. Um, but there's also probably, you know,
检查一下某个电子邮件收件箱。是的。而且这通常是由于没有与对的人取得联系而出现的问题。但是，根据你所在的国家，
there's a lot of paperwork and bureaucracy involved in forming one of these, uh, national committees, depending on the country that you're in. Um, so I'd say get it, get involved with your user group is probably the, one of the better ways. Also, if you're country that you're in. So I'd say get involved with your user group is probably one of the better ways. Also, if you are in India but work for a U.S.-based company,
组建这些国家委员会之一也可能涉及大量的文书工作和官僚作风。所以我建议，参与进你的用户组可能是更好的方法之一。另外，如果你身在印度但为一家总部设在美国的公司工作，
you could get your U.S.-based company to join the committee and then, you know, make you one of their representatives. And then, you know, it would still be through the US, but at least we would have more people in India that are involved in the C++ committee. Yeah. And C++ committee meetings will, you know, right now have been all virtual and all remote for the past two years and will be at the very least hybrid going forward. So you should be able to participate without having to worry about travel or visas or, you know, waiting 291 days to get a visitor visa appointment at the U.S. Embassy in New Delhi. All righty. Well, stay tuned over the next several years. Maybe we'll have updates for you um if and stuff ends up happening all right with that
你可以让你的美国公司加入委员会，然后，你知道的，让你成为他们的代表之一。然后，你知道的，它仍然会通过美国，但至少我们在印度会有更多人参与到 C++ 委员会中。是的。而且 C++ 委员会会议将，你知道的，在过去两年中一直是完全虚拟和远程的，并且在未来至少将是混合式的。所以你应该能够参与，而不必担心差旅或签证，或者在印度美国大使馆等待 291 天来预约访客签证。好吧，那么，在接下来的几年里请继续关注。如果事情最终发生了，也许我们会为你提供更新。好吧，就酱，
we will wrap up episode 81 thanks for listening we hope you enjoyed and have a great day There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们将结束第 81 期节目。感谢收听，希望你们喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。